okay so last week i'm sure you saw the
news that warner brothers had announced
that they were releasing their entire
2021 movie slate on hbo max
this included some of their heavy
hitters such as godzilla vs kong
the matrix 4 suicide squad tom and jerry
the conjuring and more tom and jerry
probably probably the biggest movie out
of them now it was a bold move
especially because the studios still
don't know the result of their wonder
woman 1984 experiment
to see if it's worth releasing things on
hbo max the same day that they drop in
theaters
needless to say the announcement
completely rocked the cinema world
and this business model spells doom for
a lot of theater chains
especially if other studios such as
disney follow suit
christopher nolan a big voice in the
film industry has came out and said
some some not too kind things about this
move and the guy has basically taken a
dump on hbo max
we'll get into it all in just a bit but
if this is your first time here
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
we break down all the latest movies and
tv shows and also
give you the news on the ins and outs of
the industry so if that's what you're
into
then make sure you hit the subscribe
button also i want to see how many
people
agree with nolan so make sure you hit
the thumbs up button if you do
and thumbs down if you don't now the
hollywood reporter recently dropped the
full quote from nolan on what he had to
say on the industry changing move when
discussing the matter
the director said some of our industry's
biggest filmmakers and most
important movie stars went to bed the
night before thinking they were working
for the greatest movie studio
and woke up to find out that they were
working for the worst streaming service
warner bros had an incredible machine
for getting a filmmaker's workout
everywhere
and they are dismantling it as we speak
they don't even understand what they're
losing
their decision makes no economic sense
and even the most casual wall street
investor
can see the difference between
disruption and dysfunction
pretty scathing remarks and you know
what i've heard that hbo max is actually
quite good a lot better than peacock so
i'm told
now on top of this there are rumors that
legendary studios the team behind both
godzilla vs kong
and june are actually suing the studio
as they were only told half an hour
before the announcement
that this was going to be how their
films would be released
nolan clearly isn't a fan of it and i
have to say that when i first heard the
news
i was very shocked that they'd chosen
this route especially as
films like june aren't out until october
and it could be
very likely that things are making their
way back to normal by then
i didn't initially cover this story as i
was waiting for the inevitable backlash
but i know a lot of you want to hear my
initial reaction to the delays
so i'll talk about that for just a bit
now the announcement
was i have to say very very bittersweet
i'm a cinema lover and as someone who
rarely gets out of the house
because i work from home the cinema was
my reason to go and do something
i of course love films and have a lot of
friends that work in cinema chains
which is how i get to see movies earlier
than most so
you know i can put together my videos
with such speed
fastest kid alive now not every studio
is jumping at the chance to have their
movies spoiled
so i was of course gutted for my friends
and also myself
in that i think the cinema is something
amazing and probably
the best way to watch movies especially
for the first time
i'll never forget watching the dark
knight in imax or seeing tony stark snap
his fingers because
the cinema just takes away all the
distractions and makes you focus on the
movies
however i was happy in a way as delays
have killed my channel a bit
and it's been difficult keeping the
engine going on it the last year when
there's only been about three movies
released
i know that there's a ton of people
who've had it a lot harder than i have
in the pandemic
but this is my full-time job and i
remember in may thinking
that there's no way i would make it to
the end of the year because everything
was delayed
so i appreciate all the people that have
continued to support me
you're the best now yes i know that
movies are gonna be released
and i'll have stuff to cover and it did
feel like a weight off my shoulders
however i felt that there was also a big
loss that came from this decision
nolan clearly feels the same way too i
think that announcing the entire 2021
slay as being on a streaming service
will cause a lot of issues for the
studio too piracy is gonna be like never
before
and whereas people are sometimes put off
but due to low quality
we're gonna have digital 4k versions of
films released on the same day that they
come out
hbo max is only available in the us and
like at olympia the reality of the
situation
is that people will just illegally
download the movie to watch it at home
if they can't either go to a theater or
access the service itself
i think this move by warner forces a lot
of other studios such as disney to
consider dropping things on disney plus
however that has a much bigger reach
than hbo max does
as it's available worldwide and thus
they'll probably be a lot less piracy
i heard from a mate not me they used to
watch all of the mandalorian on the day
came out because
disney plus wasn't available in the uk
and i think warner are just going to get
a lot of their content
downloaded illegally on day one so i can
see why nolan has problems with it
and as someone who pretty much forced
tenet to be released in theaters
he clearly doesn't agree with what's
going on however on the flip side of
this
there's a lot of criticism saying that
nolan is putting off before safety
and that due to the current climate
warner brothers is actually doing the
right thing
if you look on the original thread where
the article was posted
people are actually siding with warner
brothers and saying that because tennis
underperformed
that nolan himself was the reason for
this move
in the run-up to that release though it
was delayed nolim pretty much planted
his feet firmly in the ground
and said that it would have to be shown
theatrically instead of being pushed
back
and thus wb dropped it unsure of whether
it was the right thing to do or not
the director has a lot of clout and
clearly the studio tried it his way
but it didn't work they also have to
contend with the fact that they can't
keep pushing movies back
and have to make money as this will have
a knock-on effect on the films released
in 2022
the economics of not releasing these
movies is also a big factor here
and clearly they've thought long and
hard about this before making the
decision
there's also a report at the moment from
cnbc saying that hbo max
may be renamed to have warner in the
title and this makes more sense as
a lot of people think it's just hbo
content whereas
warner encompasses a lot more hopefully
we get that worldwide release too yeah
my kit my kids are dying here just
kidding i don't have kids
i i am the kid now back to nolan i think
there's a lot of people taking his
comments slightly out of context
and running with their own narrative on
it the main reason he's blasting the
studio is because they went behind the
filmmakers backs
and then told them half an hour before
dropping the announcement
clearly none of the creative team were
involved in this decision
and it's unlikely that they had any
input at all because
of how it not only shocked the movie
industry but also the movie makers
themselves
i don't think nolan is being as
dismissive towards safety as many people
are saying
and at no point does he say not to delay
the movies
rather he just doesn't want them to be
released on a streaming service because
a
they deserve bigger and b it kills
cinema chains
and makes a struggling industry have
even more of an uphill battle
i can definitely see where he's coming
from but the studio has been forced to
make this decision after trying things
his way
and clearly they also realize the value
in streaming services
netflix are of course the biggest at the
moment but over the last two weeks in
terms of subscriber growth
hbo max has completely dominated them
and that's not saying that much because
if they're smaller they obviously have
the potential to grow more
but i don't think that warner brothers
are looking to the future and realizing
that
if they can become the dominant
streaming force then they'll have a lot
more power
if hbo max does become one of the
world's biggest streaming services
because of this move
they will of course recoup the benefits
but whether that's good news for the
industry as a whole
remains to be seen now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on this news
so make sure you comment below and let
me know
if you enjoyed the video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our full breakdown of tennit which
will be linked after this
we go over the 100 best easter eggs in
the movie so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set
and all you have to do to begin with the
chances of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of december so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat us on the discord
server linked in the description or
heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you being the best i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace
just said
you